voilà pour l'actualité de ce lundi de ce
mardi 27 mars suite du journal à 2010 à
dijon avec hattrick l'ocac dijon en
effet nous nous retrouvons les toits
bourguignons de cet hôtel de vos goûts
dijon en capital de l'écologie je vous
le disais une enquête publiée il ya
quelques mois par notre confrère de
madère le point abouti c'est à cette
conclusion m il a manqué ce que cela
veut dire que signifie t'il que les riez
plus pu reprendre le monde que
l'architecturé l'urbanisme
ils sont plus intégré à l'histoire le
confort de la vie plus grand que dans
les autres cités françaises en réalité
être capital de l'écologie cela signifie
tout cela à la fois
mais il ya aussi vous allez constater
parfois un revers à une médaille 300
logements dans les centres ville de
dijon
je les à ce jeu l'effet de différentes
hauteurs
je n'aime pas tellement les l'isie dans
son cours moyen deuxième année à l'école
dampierre sophie choisi le quartier
qu'elle aimera hic le jeu une baisse de
10,6 des enfants à lui regretté un sega
qui fonde nos pilotes pour la passation
des habitants à leur profit les
immeubles anciens avocats me sophie la
muba des entreprises s'est ainsi sa
carte rouge vin ou six ans en ce sens
qu'on voit sa planque vont être
restaurés habituel 2000 rappelle
d'ailleurs c'est que sap erp dédié à
camiers mais qui alarme certains
caractères chez meridian aussi pouvoir
par des travailleurs de nouveaux rayons
dans ce que je vienne était ce quartier
le fasse vivre
adam de la promise la 6ème place lyon
nous permettra de lancer un suspect de
hlm a fait face à 17 ans par que je
m'enrichis partie développement constant
de techno a manqué beaucoup de paires
achetées et rives dans les appartements
du jour diack et de rupture des dix
jours fashion week en charge les
logements en place entre les murs de
hausse et le secteur le pays à petit ma
vie leur deuxième position enfants
non loin de là c'est qu'un tatouage sto
affaires l'enchaînent opération sans le
leur égalera gnl il m car espace vert à
thor gaz plus qu'a pris au jeu de
poumons pour coeur de la vie mais ici
pitt et à l'espoir et jardins le 18 de
ce fils année implantation de ça dans
une ancienne carrière à la fille
derrière chacun grâce aux et sincère et
aux autres éléments car dit il à se
première de ville pour le bébé notamment
d'être non mais libye l'egypte et on a
transports publics un bon appareil paru
d'alerté et ensuite est limité depuis
quand c'est l'horreur c'est de
production grâce aux marchés et qui
dénonce et park inn en vie à ce projet
sionnel le sang quand donc nos ordis
gens ont le problème les habituels
l'ensemble enfin centre de l'amener à
vivre dans les actes qui se trouve au
long et la baronne autant elle aura les
jeunes qui existent on était avec eto'o
c'est noël
tous les espaces pour y avait ont été
déduits